still to have back here on the rich
eisen show entering his sixth season
as the head coach of the atlanta falcons
dan quinn back here on the show how are
you coach
rich i'm doing good man i always enjoyed
being on the show with you so uh glad to
be on always appreciate being with you
what in the world is it like coaching
these days
dan well number one it's awesome
okay to be uh back on the field and um
you know coaching and being involved
with the players like
that part you know feels exactly like
you hope with the exception of uh
you know a mask at practice and uh so
you know
communicating you know on the field
there's you know definitely some
non-verbal
uh you know sign language that you're
having to go through because
on the field you don't get to
communicate quite
as loudly as you normally do but being
back with the team
and i've been really impressed by these
guys
just the way they came in the mindset to
go after it so it's been uh it's been
good man to get back into it the
inside the building yes which is
probably the biggest adjustments not on
the field but
you know the preparation to go play ball
and i think these guys are showing
they're earning the right to play
by you know doing the right things
making the right choices
um you know we're continuing as a nfl to
you know
small percentage of positive tests so it
takes a lot of work to take a lot of
discipline by everybody
but uh you know i think we're all
showing like we're all committed to
getting it done
and we all want to be a part of it so
damn bad that we're you know
wanted to say this is how we got to go
to to play ball and get it right
and then we're down for it yeah in a
normal year uh coach you'd be
talking about trimming your roster down
and having a final
uh preseason game coming up next week um
getting ready for
the if you will dress rehearsal um third
pre-season week
and then the final week as i mentioned
next week would be
uh for people trying to make that 53-man
roster how do you make these evaluations
currently yeah you're right i think what
uh us and i'm sure other coaches will
you know you try to create some mock
games just to make as much
game like environment as you can rich
you know there's nothing that will
you know replace that but at least you
can you know create some spaces and some
moments to do that and drill work and at
practice all right coaches on the
sideline
and then just seeing if you can almost
set up some moments to see some
match-ups that you'd like to see this
receiver in this db
you know this defensive end and the
tackle to see them really
at their best and the things that we
need to find out about
what roles for players you know a lot of
that comes you know in times for the
preseason games especially for the
newest players
to say okay what unique stuff can this
guy bring to the team
and then the player that's going from
year one to year two
those are the guys that usually make the
biggest jump so you can't just
assume what he was last year is what
he's going to be this year i think
the guy going from year one to year two
usually takes the biggest jump and i
think you have to recognize it and see
it
and say okay this is still the process
that's taken place and i think we have a
number of those players as well what
about your current rookies
we're looking at on the screen right now
you're not by television
what about these words i thought um
overall i thought the rookie class came
in with a really good
understanding and concept kind of like
you know taking a semester online
and then could they learn it and you
know you'd say well anybody can learn
the playbook
and now it's a part of the timing the
accuracy the decision making how quickly
they can go and so
they had a very good understanding more
so than most rookies of the
concepts the playbook so there's very
few mental errors taking place now it's
a matter of the speed and can you make
full speed decisions you know
when the player cuts right in front of
you those are the things that you're
seeing on a daily basis and
we just try to make as much of the
evaluations as you can and
for the rookies specifically don't try
to play perfect right now try to play
fast
because you don't want to show you know
hesitancy in your game and so
can they show they can play fast because
the mistakes you know those are things
we can coach
our way through but um you want to make
sure a player doesn't take on too much
rich because that can that can slow
a young guy down where they're just
uncertain and not really letting it rip
dan quinn here on the rich eisen show
and what i'm about to ask you is uh
this goes goes for whether you're
coaching in a pandemic or not one of the
i guess tightropes that somebody in your
position has to walk
quite a bit uh dan quinn is that when
you talk about players that have just
popped free as a free agent
people might take that to mean you're
not pleased with your current roster
or you are uh in being complimentary
about somebody else
potentially uh denigrating who you
currently have on the roster
but that said all of us in the media are
dot connectors we like connecting dots
and with earl thomas being a free agent
and you
being the dc of the legion of boom when
it was legioning and booming and coming
together a lot of people have connected
those dots
so what do you say about the possibility
of reuniting with earl thomas
coach yeah well i think two things one
i'd say
one of my favorite all-time competitors
and um i can remember all the way back i
was at it his pro day coming out of the
university of texas
and this was the player you know he
wanted to i think at the combine it was
you know
over four you know four three he wanted
it lower so like most people like now
stand on my combine numbers nope went
after it again he wanted to lower it to
you know
wanted to be in the four twos or four
three whatever i can't remember the
number but i remember him going for it
again
and so i had the chance to be around him
as a rookie
um ended the practice habits the effort
the competition
and then i left for two years and then
came back to seattle
and to see him grow into that role so
definitely one of my all-time favorite
competitors i think
the position on our team is one that
we've got
uh it's one of strength for us at safety
with keanu and ricardo
and demante kz so it's not a spot that
we're looking to address but uh you'll
always have a spot uh
you know with me in terms of uh you know
the effort the competitor i
absolutely uh love the guy but um as far
as joining our team
we're squared away where we're at safety
due to the
um you know the players that we have
there today yeah i i
i hear you on that front and in terms of
you know earl as you mentioned being one
of the best competitors and
one of the best at the position and the
hall of fame credential
again i i know it's not your team it's
somebody else's team
but the reports that my colleague mike
silver saying that that earl
part of the reason why he wore out his
welcome was that he told coaching staff
that he needed time to wash his car
in between practice and and and meetings
does
i how does that compute when you hear
and again i'm
i'm not at denigrating my colleague mike
silver gets his information right it
just
it's it's just i i don't know how to
compute with errol thomas
with what's going on i can only speak to
my experience
and uh this player showed up to walk
through
with klipton and a mouthpiece every day
so he could
put himself in the moment and uh so if
that isn't locked in
i don't know what is so um he was one of
the he had the
rare ability rich to stay focused for a
really
long time oftentimes on a friday
afternoon you know i'd be
walking out and there
you'd hear music coming from the you
know the db meeting room and
i knew who it was because it was his
last checklist of going through things
on a friday afternoon when
most of the building had left and i just
pop in i say man is there any questions
that are coming up in your mind and
um you know if you did we talked about
him but um
those were just two small examples of uh
of like how locked in a person can be uh
on the moment he had the rare ability
just to keep a focus for a really long
time which is not easy for
not just the ball player but for anybody
yeah i remember that 2010 draft
um coach where again uh pete carroll
just come from usc and we all knew that
uh they needed you know seattle needed
to take a safety everybody assumed it
would be taylor mays
because pete would know him and he would
just one with him and
no it's earl thomas from texas and it
kind of threw everyone for a loop but we
all saw
we all saw what happened after that
first draft choice of the carol
schneider era in seattle
yeah with the
the same draft of the competitiveness
of what it stood for and uh you know
certainly at secondary you know like
pete had a
you know remarkable role for what they
would do right away but
earl came in um as one of the best
practicing players right off the bat the
speed the intensity and i think
probably during my time through the nfl
two players
stood out to me out at a defensive
background you know that i'll say in san
francisco it would have been bryant
young
and in miami junior stay out and so
earl came to seattle with some of those
traits of a guy who
just would go for it and i just
remember sending um some tape to uh
one of my friends who was in college to
say you want to know how like they were
asked about practice tempo
and i sent tape of earl to say this is
what it should look like
dan quinn here on the rich eisen show i
guess while we're strolling down memory
lane a little bit here and just uh
preparing for this you know i just went
down your your your history
and uh you were the d-line coach i guess
your first gig as a coach in 1994
william and mary was mike tomlin on that
team
when you were coming mike was a senior
wide receiver yes so we were just a year
apart
and uh that's where our connection began
um so
it was a lot of fun and sean mcdermott
was a sophomore safety on that team
come on really come on man yeah were
they coachable were they coachable or
you really needed to
prod them a little bit no they were 100
accessible
and uh so mike and i we he was you know
a captain on that team and
a year after i had gone to bmi
and that spring when mike was graduating
um we needed a receiver coach
and i remember telling bill stewart i
said well mike tomlin wants to coach he
said the receiver at william i said yeah
it took him about
he interviewed the next day and had the
job in about 15 minutes you know like
mike was coaching you know while he was
still playing like he had that kind of
um connection with people and so like i
said i was just a year apart from him so
um it wasn't the normal uh coach player
relationship if there was a
time to go out and have a beer together
the one who called you when you were in
hofstra and uh to give you a job or
and offer you a job of uh uh quality
control on defense for the niners and
insisted
you put your wife on the phone too right
that's how he yeah
he's such a stud and it was like the
best runway for someone to go into pro
ball you know like think about learning
something from mooch
and so staff meetings team meetings you
know like i got to
see what it could look like and so for
you know two years with them i just got
to see a model of what something done
really remarkably well could look like
and i thought what an
excellent way to enter into the nfl and
it
formed a lot of um you know the
standards that that i have today were
you know based on the things that steve
did
you know as a coach way back dan quinn
here on the rich eisen show how is matt
ryan we haven't spoken to the natural
well i'm not going to give up on just
yet
um yeah it's got to come back to ice
eventually for you i know that i know
that i know that
so how does and we'll get him on soon
i'll ask him directly but uh from your
perspective the fact that brady's now on
this division
brady breeze i mean the the non-stop
conversation we're hearing about that
how does he uh take that i imagine this
is a challenge for somebody deep in his
career with a
resume like he's already put up for this
franchise yeah and i would think
um for those that know him uh the dog
competitor that he is
um he went after it in the off season
and so you can when we got the training
camp you can see the work that he put in
with julio
and hayden and calvin ridley and russell
gage and so they spent the gun
together here in georgia out in
california they took a break went out
there to throw some so
that connection that's to me the best
competitive advantage there is
rich is when a team comes together and
they have
communication and moments and ways that
they connect and so
this is a group that is connected um
certainly at you know wide receiver and
now hadn't paid into
our tight end core um and that's at the
front and center of that for sure
yeah and then uh the one with maybe the
largest chip could be gurley
um and todd coming in and man we keep on
asking this question out here in los
angeles i'm going to ask it to you and
try and you see
is this young man healthy is his
knee ready to roll in the national
football league
dan quinn yeah it certainly looks that
way to us rich he's
um answered and delivered on all the
practice moments the
conditioning is in shape the you know
all the stuff that he's
just like everybody else you know going
through it and he's bigger than i
thought no wonder he's got so many
touchdowns down the red zone this is a
big dude who can
uh catch the ball out of the backfield
um but
i really uh am enjoying getting to know
him um
just like we are with all the teammates
but for the newer guys how do they find
their own way
one day you know connecting with
linebackers and dbs and i said has that
always been the case he said yeah all
the way back from high school i always
had a good
relationship with the defensive side and
so you see a guy building
a relationship on a team not just on the
offensive side but but all across and
that's certainly the case with julio and
matt and some of the other team leaders
here as well so
i've been very impressed by what i've
seen so far with todd and i preface this
question i swear
i'm not asking this about fantasy
football whatsoever
but you know it is because it does give
you a window of
what you're expecting here what about
touches for todd gurley what do you what
are you hoping is the sweet spot of
touches for todd gurley in your offense
dan quinn you know we haven't we haven't
gone down that space as much as just
we've got to make sure we have like a
complimentary and a balanced attack rich
because that's when we're at our best
it's run game it's play pass and so say
there'll be some games um that will have
more
um just based on the you know the scheme
that we're playing but
it should always be a healthy dose for
us just because for us
balance um is going to be a big part of
what we do our run and play passes
that's where so many explosive passes
come from
so but we're certainly uh not heading
into our season with any
uh limitations in that space uh
regarding todd because he's just
he's hitting all the marks here he
worked incredibly hard um
you know back in l.a and during the off
season and uh
you can definitely see he put that work
in you know out of the practice and
finally on your defense uh i couldn't
help but notice mckinley saying that he
has
it kind of uh shocked him uh
made him uh kind of a little bit more
aware of uh the realities by not getting
his option picked up for his fifth year
this young man that's uh uh important to
your team
uh what what does that mean to hear that
from from uh
this kid that's right up there up front
for you dan yeah and for sure it's not
you know all these situations not one
size fits all so one of the things i've
been impressed by him
um he had to go through a soldier a
shoulder surgery during the off-season
and
in conjunction with that um changing his
diet his nutrition so for him to come
back lighter than he's been
in a long time the speed part of his
game was something that
is one of his strengths let's make sure
that you're light enough to that
always shows up and so he's another guy
that i thought really put in good work
he wanted when the pandemic kind of hit
we had a vision that they
would we be able to come out stronger
than we went into it
and a lot of individual planning for the
players went in and they took it really
seriously they had
all of april all of may all of june
devoted mostly to their skill work their
strength their conditioning
rehab and tax case so a number of them
came into camp stronger and um
i don't know more you know a mentality
that had been even
you know come stronger than in years
past so
that part it made getting into training
camp uh a lot of fun to get started
last one for you i asked this of bill
belichick yesterday uh coach i'll ask
you as well if you could wave a wand and
change a rule in the rule book that dan
quinn rule
would be what what would you change in
the nfl man that's a good one
i think um if i had to i prefer the
pi for the college side of things
sometimes i think the
the 40-yard penalty down the field
that's an expensive one
uh certainly as a defensive coach but um
yeah i think that'd be one that that
first one that popped into my head so
i'm going with that would you like to
know what belichick said
are you curious yeah i would the same
thing
well he said that that he wants you know
everyone to take a look at it he just he
he wants consistency between the college
and the pro game he said
if the college game changes to the pros
okay but if the pros got to change the
college he would
he would prefer to take a look at it um
but that's the that's the
that's the same thing he said the same
thing
it's a big one you know for like a
personal foul or an unnecessary
roughness or unsportsman like
gets less than a big pi but um hey it's
all part of the competitiveness that
makes it good and we're going but yep
i'm glad i think if you ask all the
coaches some of the defensive ones
i don't think any of the offensive
coaches would say so just say to it and
let it fly
oh man coach thanks for the time always
appreciate our chats
really do all right thanks right back at
you you got it that's dan quinn
atlanta falcons head coach how about
that hey you watched all the way to the
end
thanks for that watch more right here